walking. I'm in Cincinnati right
now. I haven't seen this
many bangle shirts and stripes
and my lifetime Vegas coming
off that overtime win and
descent. See, how do you see
this one playing out?
Well, I'm not going to give you
too much information, but
I think the thing that I'm
watching is how quickly can
the Raiders turn around and, and
bring that same energy. They
went into overtime. They
expelled a lot of energy, very
exciting game. A lot of
times to the, it's hard to come
back and
play with that same level of
energy. So that's what I'm
watching. It. Can they come back
and match that energy?
After an overtime game in the
way, that one was. And I always
think it's a lot harder flying
to the east coast because you
lose all those times. I lose all
those hours, man. I took,
I took the red-eye last night,
this I, you know, my right eyes
pretty straight,
just a little crooked, you know,
and so Vegas. Gonna have to deal
with all that.
How about the New England
Patriots in the Buffalo Bills?
Those two they know each other
so, well made first thought.
For me, I'm focused on Matt
Jones and Matt Jones and he
talked about he was embarrassed
man. Don't be embarrassed to
get better. You got to do a
better job and now it's
the playoffs. You're no longer a
rookie
and you know, the Buffalo Bills
are going to show you different
looks so Mac, you got to step
up. If, if we want to win.
I can't wait to watch that game
and we're going to learn
something about. We're, learn
something about Mac. That's how
I feel about it.